preparing for this talk has been scarier
for me than preparing for LSD therapy
psychedelics are to the study of the
mind what the microscope is to biology
and the telescope is to astronomy dr.
stanislav grof spoke those words he's
one of the leading psychedelic
researchers in the world and he's also
been my mentor today I'd like to share
with you how psychedelics when used
wisely have the potential to help heal
us help inspire us and perhaps even to
help save us in the 1950s and 60s
psychedelic research flourished all over
the world and showed great promise for
the fields of psychiatry psychology and
psychotherapy neuroscience and the study
of mystical experiences but psychedelics
leaked out of the research settings and
began to be used by the counterculture
and by the anti-vietnam war movement and
there was unwise use and so there was a
backlash and in 1970 the US government
criminalized all uses of psychedelics
and they began shutting down all
psychedelic research and this ban spread
all over the world and lasted for
decades and it was tragic
since psychedelics are really just tools
and whether their outcomes are
beneficial or harmful depend on how
they're used
psychedelic means mind manifesting and
it relates to drugs like LSD psilocybin
mescaline I boga and other drugs when I
was 18 years old I was a college
freshman I was experimenting with LSD
and mescaline and these experiences
brought me in touch with my emotions and
they helped me have a spiritual
connection that unfortunately
my bar mitzvah did not produce when I
wanted to tease my parents I would tell
them that they drove me to psychedelics
because my bar Mista had failed to turn
me into a man but most importantly
psychedelics gave me this feeling of our
shared humanity of our unity with all
life and other people reported that same
thing as well
and I felt that these experiences had
the potential to help be an antidote to
tribalism to fundamentalism to genocide
an environmental destruction and so I
decided to focus my life on changing the
laws and becoming a legal psychedelic
psychotherapist now half a century after
the ban were in the midst of a global
renaissance of psychedelic research
psychedelic psychotherapy is showing
great promise for the treatment of
post-traumatic stress disorder or PTSD
depression social anxiety substance
abuse and alcoholism and suicide
psychedelic psychotherapy is an attempt
to go after the root causes of the
problems with just a relatively few
administrations as contrasted to most of
the psychiatric drugs used today that
are mostly just reducing symptoms and
are meant to be taken on a daily basis
psychedelics are now also being used as
tools for neuroscience to study brain
function and to study the enduring
mystery of human consciousness and
psychedelics and the mystical
experiences they produce are being
explored for their connections between
meditation and mindfulness including a
paper just recently published about
lifelong Zen meditators taking
psilocybin in the midst of a meditation
retreat and showing long-term benefits
and brain changes now how do these drugs
work modern neuroscience research has
demonstrated that psychedelics reduce
activity in what's known as the brains
default mode network this is where we
create our sense of self
it's our equivalent to the ego and it
filters all incoming information
according to our personal needs and
priorities when activity is reduced in
the default mode Network our ego shifts
from the foreground to the background
and we see that it's just part of a
larger field of awareness it's similar
to the shift that Copernicus and Galileo
were able to produce in humanity using
the telescope to show that the earth was
no longer the center of the universe but
was actually something that revolved
around the Sun something bigger than
itself for some people this shift in
awareness is the most important and
among the most important experiences of
their lives they feel more connected to
the world bigger than themselves they
feel more altruistic and they lose some
of their fear of death not all drugs
work this way MDMA also known as ecstasy
or Molly works fundamentally different
and I'll be able to share with you the
story of Marcela who suffered from
post-traumatic stress disorder from a
violent sexual assault Marcela and I
were introduced in 1984 when MDMA was
still legal but it was beginning also to
leak out of therapeutic circles Marcela
had tried MDMA in a recreational setting
and during that her past trauma flooded
her awareness and it intensified her
suicidal feelings during our first
conversation I shared that when MDMA was
is taken therapeutically it can reduce
the fear of difficult emotions and she
could help move forward past her trauma
I asked her to promise not to commit
suicide if we were to work together and
she agreed and made that promise during
her therapeutic sessions Marcela was
able to process her trauma more fluidly
more easily and yet she was able to tell
that the rapist had told her that if she
ever shared her story he would kill her
and she realized that that was keeping
her a prisoner in her own mind and so
being able to share the story and
experience the feelings and the thoughts
in her mind freed her and she was able
to decide that she wanted to move
forward with her life and in that moment
I realized that MDMA could be very
effective for treating PTSD now at 35
years later after Marcela's treatment
she's actually a therapist training
other therapists to help people overcome
PTSD with MDMA now how does MDMA work
how did MDMA help Marcela people who
have PTSD have brains that are different
from those of us who don't have PTSD
they have a hyperactive amygdala where
we process fear they have reduced
activity in the prefrontal cortex where
we think logically and they have reduced
activity in the hippocampus where we
store our memories into long-term
storage and the am a changed is the
brain in the opposite way
MDMA reduces activity in the amygdala
increases activity in the frontal cortex
and increases connectivity between the
amygdala and the hippocampus to remit
traumatic memories to move into
long-term storage recently researchers
at Johns Hopkins published a paper in
Nature in which they demonstrated that
MDMA releases oxytocin the hormone of
love and nurturing these same
researchers also did studies in
octopuses who are normally a social
unless it's mating season but lo and
behold you give them MDMA and they
become pro-social several months after
Marcella and I worked together the Drug
Enforcement Administration moved to
criminalize ecstasy having no knowledge
of its therapeutic use so I went to
Washington and I went into the
headquarters of the Drug Enforcement
Administration and I filed a lawsuit
demanding a hearing at which
psychiatrists and psychotherapists would
be able to present information about
therapeutic use of MDMA to try to keep
it legal and in the middle of the
hearing
the DEA freaked-out declared an
emergency and criminalized all uses of
MDMA and so the only way that I could
see to bring it back was through science
through medicine and through the FDA
drug development process so in 1986 I
started maps as a non-profit psychedelic
pharmaceutical company
it took us 30 years till 2016 to develop
the data that we needed to present to
FDA to request permission to move into
the large-scale phase three studies that
are required to prove safety and
efficacy before you get approval for
prescription use tony was a veteran in
one of our pilot studies according to
the Veterans Administration there's over
a million veterans now disabled with
PTSD and at least 20 veterans a day are
committing suicide many of them from
PTSD the treatment that tony was to
receive was three and a half months long
but during that period of time he would
only get MDMA on three occasions
separated by 12 90-minute non drug
psychotherapy sessions three before the
first MDMA session for preparation and
three after each MDMA session for
integration we call our tree gnam
approach inner-directed therapy and that
we support the patient to experience
whatever is emerging within their minds
or their bodies even with MDMA this is
hard work and a lot of our subjects have
said I don't know why they call this
ecstasy during Tony's first MDMA session
he lay on the couch he had I shades on
he listened to music and he would speak
to the therapists who are a male-female
Kothari's whenever he felt that he
needed to after several hours in a
moment of calmness and clarity
Tony shared that he had realized that
his PTSD was a way of connecting him to
his friends it was a way of honoring the
memory of his friends who had died but
he was able to shift and see himself
through the eyes of his dead friends
and he realized that they would not want
him to suffer to squander his life they
would want him to live more fully which
they were unable to do and so he
realized that there was a new way to
honor their memory which was to live as
fully as possible he also realized that
he was telling himself a story that he
was taking opiates for pain but actually
he realized he was taking them for
escape and so he decided he didn't need
the opiates anymore he didn't need the
MDMA anymore and he was dropping out of
the study that was seven years ago
tony is still free of PTSD has never
returned to opiates and is helping
others less fortunate than himself in
Cambodia the data that we presented to
FDA from 107 people in our pilot studies
including Tony showed that 23 percent of
the people that received therapy without
active MDMA no longer had PTSD at the
end of treatment this is really pretty
good for this patient population however
when you add MDMA the results more than
double to 56 percent no longer having
PTSD but but most importantly once
people learn that if they don't need to
suppress their trauma but they can
process it they keep getting better on
their own so at the 12-month follow-up
one year after the last treatment
session 2/3 no longer have PTSD and of
the one-third that do many have
clinically significant reductions in
symptoms on the basis of this data
the FDA has declared mdma-assisted
psychotherapy for PTSD a breakthrough
therapy FDA has also declared psilocybin
a breakthrough therapy for treatment
resistant depression and just recently
approved s ketamine for depression I'm
proud to say that we have now initiated
our phase 3 studies and if the results
are as we hope and if they're similar to
the phase 2 studies by the end of 2021
FDA will
prove mdma-assisted psychotherapy for
PTSD if approved the only therapist that
will be able to directly administer it
to patients are going to be therapists
that have been through our training
program and they will only be able to
administer MDMA under direct supervision
in clinic settings we anticipate that
over the next several decades there will
be thousands of psychedelic clinics
established at which therapists will be
able to administer and BMA psilocybin
ketamine and other psychedelics to
potentially millions of patients these
clinics can also evolve into centers
where people can come for psychedelic
psychotherapy for personal growth for
couples therapy or for spiritual
mystical experiences humanity now is in
a race between catastrophe and
consciousness the psychedelic
Renaissance is here to help
consciousness triumph and now if you all
just look under your seats
just joking thank you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
not many of them have also been to
Burning Man yeah so in your talk you
talked about using these drugs to
address some pretty serious traumas so
what about some more common mental
illnesses like anxiety and depression
and is that where micro dosing comes in
well micro dosing can be helpful for
depression I do know someone that has
been using it but in general for
therapeutic purposes we prefer macro
dosing rather than micro dosing in order
to really help people deal with the root
causes micro dosing is more for
creativity for artistic inspiration for
focus and it's also does have a mood
elevation lift but I think for serious
illnesses we'd rather not get people
thinking that they need a daily drug but
do more deeper intense work and what
about outside the United States and
North America is this research being
done there oh yeah we're globalizing our
phase three studies are actually being
done in Israel Canada and the United
States so once we get approval an FDA
it'll also become approved in Israel and
in Canada we're just starting research
in Europe and we're actually going to be
training some therapists from China
that's great we were gonna do an
audience vote to see if people felt like
this was a good idea to move forward
this research or not but I have a
feeling I know the answer to that so
thank you so much Rick thank you thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]